First day we got stuck on the first day
Welcome to game transect
7:00 a.m. In the morning
Brem bambridge, this is the Studios for basically all of Winterfell
Quite young and I had such a big imagination in those scenes when I was younger
I would have really convinced myself that I was there and it was happening
You know
I'd never had any experience of acting before I went to a very
theatrically based drama school 33 hours of camera trained in three years
Well, then my fourth hour in front of a camera was day one on Game of Thrones
My first day on set was Castle black
My first scene was just a very quick scene where I'm walking down the ramparts and I was so nervous
Jesus my first job but this is like the first thing I ever did and they said we're no horse. Oh
I was falling off the horse trying to act still
I
Remember my first scene we shot from the pilot and that was the Kings
Arrival and the King rides in on horseback and he has to get off this horse and his robe was enormous
the horse rides in he's like
and then
Hold everyone and then they run in with thank you like a ladder
They help him down and run out with the lad and then carry on
I
Made me remember it was like Sean Bean and Mark Adi and Lina and I remember being so overwhelmed and terrified
I remember everybody clear
I remember baby Sophie and baby, Maisie and baby Isaac and now they're you know out there full grown and here we are
season 8 its cinematic
We're making 10 hour movies every year the fact that this is really a full stop
On this story is sad because I think everyone's been so invested in this story
That we never want to see this just come to a close, but it must and it will be good
Everybody, it's Charlie. They dropped a couple new behind the scenes promos for Game of Thrones season 8 episode 1
We're literally almost a day away from episode 1 getting here
so we'll break some of this down because the actors also talked about the very first scene that they filmed during season 8 in the
Very first scene that they filmed on the series in general way way back during season 1 there was also a really interesting
Question that you guys asked me about the night in Winterfell in terms of what he can and can't do using his magic
So we'll explain that to there's a lot of historical context for Winterfell magic
Bran, the Builder going way way back to the building of the wall
If you're brand new to my channel, be sure to subscribe to get all the season 8 videos
We'll be doing that weekly HBO now giveaway - all you have to do to enter that is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video the footage you see here is basically
Jon Snow Sansa bran Stark Brienne of Tarth mists and I Jorah Mormont Davos
obviously if they're sitting there then Emilia Clarke is somewhere else - because we've actually gotten a couple more pictures of this scene that they're
filming inside the Great Hall of Winterfell
Apparently that was the very first scene that they filmed for season 8 you have Daenerys
Sansa John sitting at the table then in this shot here
You can actually see bran sitting way off in the background right next to the table on the left side of the frame where Brienne
Is sitting next to the little bear yawn and Davos Sansa is still wearing her old outfit from last season
she hasn't got that leather armor upgrade that you see in all those other pictures that might come later in the episode or maybe during
Episode 2 but Daenerys gets a whole bunch of costume changes
So it makes sense that salsa, but have a bunch of costume changes as well
They talk about all their funny moments during the very first scene that they filmed during season 1 episode 1 for the pilot episode
I assume that they're talking about the legit pilot and not the scrapped pilot that everybody keeps making fun of Nikolaj coster-waldau
Jaime Lannister was making fun of that
original pilot a little while ago during an interview who knows if we'll ever get to see footage of that but they keep saying that
It's terrible
so I assume that they won't release that the funny thing about kit harington's very first scene is he said he was up at the
Wall, so he'd already taken the black at that point in the story
Just walking along that corridor trying not to mess up
But then when sophie Turner is talking about her very first scene as Sansa Stark
She's talking about when Robert Baratheon arrived and Nikolaj
Coster-waldau also talks about some of the funny moments during that look trying to get Robert off of his horse like it took a whole
Bunch of crew members they had to put a giant box next to the horse just because his robe was so long in a wound
Up being so awkward that they had to cut around it
I'm assuming most of the other stark children like Maisie Williams
also had their very first scene in this moment - if salsa was having her first scene then but you noticed Jon Snow in the
Background of that shot. So he was here for that scene in Kit Harington was filming before this
So I'm assuming the scene of Robert Baratheon and the Lannisters meeting the stars happened much later in the filming schedule
Than some of this early stuff up at the wall
But like when John Bradley talks about his first moments as Sam up on set he didn't actually join the show till after the pilot
Seems like the only person in this video that talks about having his first seen that wasn't during the pilot the interesting thing about
Amelia Clarke's first day on said that she talks about obviously. It's a funny story
She kept falling off her horse because she didn't know how to ride a horse. She was right out of school
So it's just really awkward. She kind of chuckles her way through it, but this scene didn't happen in the pilot episode
They actually put it during episode two
So maybe they just filmed it while they were filming all these pilot scenes and thought that it worked better during episode two
But if you ever go back and you watch the pilot
which you may have done recently if you look at the scene of
Robert and Ned in the crypts going to lyanna stark's statue
You notice that Sean beans hair looks very different from the earlier scene when they're in the courtyard
That's because they reach out a lot of that courtyard scene
But the scene of them in the crypts is from the original pilot
The reason why he looks so different is because in that original pilot
They made Jaime
Lannister Ned Stark all the older characters look a little bit younger than they do in the final version of the pilot that we all
Wound up seeing so sort of
Transitioning to that big Winterfell night King theory that people have been asking me you all remember that first Game of Thrones Season 8 trailer
Where we got footage of Varys the women and children like Gilly and baby Sam in the crypts
hiding during the big battle of Winterfell
There are a lot of people since then that have asked me if the night King could use his magic to raise all the stark
Dead in the crypts like if the night king can raise anybody that's dead
technically if you have a bunch of dead bodies in this underground
Graveyard couldn't he raise them as White's and use them as fodder for his army
The show is also set precedent that the night king can turn full skeletons into White Walkers
it doesn't have to be a
Freshly dead person because season 4 episode 10 when they're all trying to enter the three-eyed Ravens cape all those Ray
Harryhausen looking skeleton White's come up like a bunch of landmines to try and stop them from entering
If you know a little bit about the origins of Winterfell its history actually goes back to the creation of the wall
Bran, the Builder was supposed to have built Winterfell after he built the wall with the help of the Giants
So the Giants helped build the wall, but the Giants also helped build Winterfell. The thing is though
Is that most of the original structures above ground from that time have not survived bran the Builder built the wall many
Thousands of years ago way before the Andals invaded the oldest part of Winterfell right now. That's still standing is the first Keeffe
That's where brand accidentally caught Cersei and Jaime playing hide the pickle and they got pushed out the window things I do for love
That was built around the time of the Andal invasion which was a couple thousand years after the creation of Winterfell
So there's still like a lot of older structures that just didn't survive except for the godswood in the crypts because bran the Builder
built Winterfell around the godswood for very specific reason and if you notice the crypts even though they're underground are
Located right next to the godswood
So think about it this way if there was special magic used to enchant the wall when it was built
Bran, the Builder would have known about that
He also probably had some enchantments laid on Winterfell that helped protect it but this is many thousands of years ago in in present-day
What just happened a couple seasons ago bran was marked by the night king
The three-eyed raven said that because he's marked you that's broken the enchantment on the wall, and he can now pass south
It's not enough to just use Vissarion to melt the wall
He had to break the enchantment before he could use the dragon to do that
so if you consider that the idea of the three-eyed Raven the person that holds that enchantment and keeps it in place is a
Transitive thing like it's passed from one person to another the three-eyed Raven tells brand it's time for you to become me and uploads his
consciousness and all of his knowledge in his magic into brand
So when the night King broke the enchantment on the wall by marking brand
He also probably broke any other enchantments that were laid around the creation of the wall, which would be the stuff down at Winterfell
So if there were special
enchantments
Protecting the crypts at Winterfell to keep the dead from rising again because of bran the Builder
Built the crypts and he knew all about the White Walkers
That he would probably try to do something to prevent any of the stark dead from being used against them
But even if any magical protections from the crypts are gone think about it this way from a practical standpoint varus
ghillie, baby
Sam will all probably survive beyond the Battle of Winterfell
Meaning that there probably aren't any whites that are raised down there the doors to the crypts are made of iron wood
Which is really hard to burn with anything, but say like dragon fire or vissarion's fire
So it really is one of the safest places to go in Winterfell
The crypts themselves are actually much much larger underground than the above-ground castle of Winterfell itself
So you said to imagine with this giant iceberg of dead people underneath Winterfell?
The further down you go in the crypts the older the stark dead
So you get to guess the brand the builder is probably buried on the lowest level
But they say that the lower levels have all been collapsed
So hopefully that explains just from a practical standpoint why they probably won't be raising a whole bunch of undead stark
Skeletons during the Battle of Winterfell. I may do one more bonus video before episode 1 happens Sunday
They're also doing a special panel for the Mandalorian Star Wars TV series
So I'll do a trailer video for that to leave all your requests in the comments below or remind everybody about the HBO now giveaway
In my episode 1 video on Sunday. I named a giveaway winner on Monday when I post that episode 2 trailer video
so while you wait for everything click here for all my Game of Thrones Season 8 trailer videos and bonus videos and click here for
That brand new star wars episode 9 trailer
Congratulations everybody. The long wait is over. I'll see you guys tonight